além do português o porto cissokho do
porto para o mesmo assim nasce no porto
sou criado no porto e moro em matosinhos
a nato gente conheça a verdade mas é
como a importância que agora entretanto
a imagem que tem eu sou suspeito cidade
mais bonita do mundo transporta porto
andré gomes atribuiu seu desempenho mas
não estamos é esse o adepto do futebol
com o comportamento do jovem um pouco
como convidado especial porque joão é é
um dos voluntários o teste voluntário há
muito orgulho que eu estou aqui no
trailer que se realiza em 2017
é com muito orgulho e satisfação que
estou neste último que eu não acredito
que seja o último
marcos lorena obrigado pelo convite mas
eu não acredito que seja o último e no
cheiro já que ele fez que sim pode não
ser o ano passado estive aqui como
voluntário em setembro lembro que eu
tenho já comigo 21 telex 21 este
objetivo segundo a mãe caiu 12 no texas
como voluntário 2 telex como
organizadora do site com participantes
está o meu primeiro como lo os únicos
três estrangeiros a nível internacional
só o legal e pelo segundo ano é que
melhoramos a yoki perfeito é esse é
maravilhoso
o ano passado tinha um enorme orgulho e
uma satisfação grande
aqui esta gente maravilhosa da galiza
santiago de compostela corunha pedra só
sejam maravilhosos que a pergunta é como
como acabar com essa guerra está
queremos ou não queremos ou não acabasse
em santiago praticamente conhecer
conhecer galiza já não se eu sou
apaixonada eu sou um homem de paixões
eu também sou um apaixonado pelos
caminhos de santiago e neste momento já
só com frase do apóstolo santiago 30 37
anos ganha filhos levam tvcom 30 do
nosso telex
então o caminho caminhada caminhada já
fiz o caminho o caminho é para três
vezes desde que faça melhor
o primeiro do mesmo português a porta a
240 quilômetros segundo o tamanho bem
desde valença e outros 10 desde ferrou o
caminho inglês chama inglesa seja agora
é maravilhoso
uma mãe não em apaixonado geral está
devendo assim está apaixonado por tudo
que nós queremos é como voluntário
praticamente não deu tempo pra festa
voluntariado uma farsa é fácil é uma
história curta em poucos anos eu em 2013
tinha um trabalho normal com toda a
gente trabalhava de segunda a sexta 14h
armado o escritório escrita números é
uma conversa que tive com a minha mulher
estava saturado e deixei trabalhar com
50 anos de gaza uma coragem imensa tem
três filhos que aquela precisão enfim
conhece
é e com o consentimento entre um caminho
que o sentimento da minha mulher em um
acordo com minha mulher e eu deixei e
descobri uma coisa que é tão maravilhosa
que é o que chama voluntária' vão que
nos motiva que nos apaixona que nos dá
nos engrandece de uma maneira tão grande
que toda a gente as variedades comentar
o que é ser voluntário o que está
achando um relato muito frequente não
não tenho trabalho está sentado assim
quase engenheiro quase ninguém fazer
isto é impossível lembrou da infância no
grupo mas nós estamos a falar em 2010
estamos a falar num curto espaço de
tempo de três anos em que eu não faço o
telex
eu já faço tudo que está ligado com
doenças coisas que se a suíça em que
estou
a liga portuguesa contra o cancro
[Música]
autismo
faço coisas ligadas à música agora
também tento não ser voluntário e um
aproveitamento que há muita gente que
aproveita de um voluntário por ser
gratuito dinheiro tirando proveito
declarou
eu não quero dinheiro quero que as
pessoas valorizem o voluntário e neste
momento só faço mais voluntariado a
nível da coordenação eu tenho um grupo
de voluntários que trabalham para mim a
vontade pra mim é tratá lo eu só preciso
faça o trabalho voluntário para não ser
prejudicado
eu tenho tenho que valorizar muito
aquela pessoa que é o seu tempo
gratuitamente em prol de alguns alguma
ao objetivo comum a busca de 1 100 eu é
muito amor é muito apaixonada e também a
busca do bem comum na cidade
deveria ser obrigatório nas escolas nós
porque não sabiam que cristiano já com o
sentido voluntariado é era muito bom já
teria sido responsável
é natural as crianças também sim a
imagem atual momento é simplesmente a
competitividade das crianças para que
não é mais fácil nas crianças que não
nos adultos
sem dúvida podemos entrar um pouquinho
no teto o que você tomou lhe a minha
outra gerar efetivamente estamos aqui na
galiza é fácil
eu sei que há um ano passava não
conhecia ninguém
o marco zero tão à vontade
eu fiquei ali naquela porta é receber as
pessoas sempre como eu sou jackson as
pessoas sempre tentei sempre com sorriso
com educação eu fui assim o crescimento
é isso que eu tenho de passar às oitavas
vencendo aqui com o meu ego
grana mesmo esta gente toda está no meu
coração mesmo quando quando o marcos
falou comigo se eu queria ser duradouras
eu gostaria que eu pensava poder vir a
ser o orador do islã em 2017 que era o
último
como é que eu podia dizer que não o
último nunca acaba e união português
falará em público por incrível que
parece que por incrível que pareça são
os vizinhos só podia estar aqui estou
aqui de coração cheio
pois achava que render homenagem porque
te para também bater conta que não é
comum também sentirá a nossa cidade e
digamos noite parece o velho no meio das
crianças é um trabalho muito bem no meio
das crianças descreveu o trabalho muito
bem dos mais jovens apesar que eu acho
que os jovens deveriam ter um bocadinho
mais responsável e dela mas são
fantásticos do trabalhador que os
resolvemos enquanto o resto quando podem
ver de fora nomes como álvaro também já
sabe outra paixão como novo foi entender
como pastel matéria teve como deixa a
vida me levar a campanha para captar o
dinheiro deixa a vida me levar e se ele
arranjou ainda 54 anos é filha de cinco
anos
outro filho de 14 uma filha dos acertos
só posso ter um grande orgulho depois
nesse grande orgulho ter duas mães
porque os meus fãs de 2001 os filhos mas
foi são filhos de uma mãe e esta é a
princesa filha da empresa está aquém do
tamanho tem muita sorte com as duas mães
crippa os meus filhos têm muita gente a
mais fantástica e as praias tamanho
sou grato porque o time foi bom queremos
fazer uma homenagem na crônica joão
aproveita para homenagear toda
voluntariado participou no resgae que
aconteceu a última mulher mais velha do
que eu não sei joão aqui a ser
apresentado
eu quero coisa que sei é que quero estar
aqui aposentar e saiu em auxílio todo o
trabalho todos voluntários do trabalho
fantástico que fazem o tempo dependendo
das suas vivas de tudo tudo tudo tudo
que não é a assinada por isso peço um
grande abraço grande baixa para dar
[Música]